puni 2
先に言っときますけどこの椅子あんまり意味はないんです
あの尺八が出て歌手が出て芸人を挟んでへパーが出ていっ
主トークだけなので
心もとないんでこれをいたってことなんですけど
なので期待しないでくださ
私もともと医者をしてたんです
でも今病院で働かずに起業しています
何をしてるかというと健康でいられる時間と寿命
そのギャップヘルスライフギャップそういったものをどう解消するか
に取り組んでいます
将来今を振り返ったときにあの頃ってどうやって健康を守ってたん脚気
そう思わせたいというのが願いなんです
医者で mba で起業してるなんていうといかにもグローバル課題を
イノベーティブにシンプルなんていういわゆるセクシービジネスモデルみたいなを期待
されちゃうんですけども
僕みたいな社会起業家にとっては
そんな綺麗な言葉よりも
実はもっと
ローカルで複雑な課題を地道に解決する
そっちの方がずっと重要なんです
実はこの話はこれ1時間ぐらいしゃべるんですけど今日の本題ではないんです
肩すかしみたいですいませんそれからもう一つ言っておきたいのは
他の子の出身なんですけども母校でテックスというババアを与えられてしかも大して
優秀な学生でもなかったんですけれどもこの安田コードの男女でしゃべるというすごい
ありがたいことなのでこの場を借りて本当にあの感謝したいと思っています
学生時代に勉強を無理してなかったというは言いましたけれども
卒業してから仕事をしなかったわけでは当然なくてきちんと医者をやってたんです
医者の仕事は皆さんも想像できるかもしれませんけどもすごい家キムで昼間は常に患者
さんもいますし
夜は救急車に乗って通院する患者さんいるっていうずっと患者さんを診ているわけです
忙しすぎるので家はほとんど寝るだけに帰る場所だったりそもそも家があっても病院に
寝泊まりする
そんな生活をしていますこれ
ですから病院を離れた今でも今働いている医療職の人たちをいつも尊敬しているんです
医療は実は
実はと言うとがあるんですけど皆さんご存知のように何かしら困った人が病院に行って
きて
その方々を助ける遭遇仕事です
しかも命を使ってますし患者さんから感謝もされます
そうするとこのを助けているとか命を扱っているあるいは感謝される
こうしたことがものすごい充実感になって忙しい現場を支えています
私もかつてそうでした
医者仲間たちと
辛いなぁ苦しいなぁと思いながらでもそのとてつもない充実感を感じてしようとしてた
んです
でも一方でこういう見方をすることもできます
誰かが困っているように車でビューの中で待ってていいんですか
それってあたかも崖下で上から落ちてくる人を待っているような医療ってそんなもんだ
んでしたっけ
そういう違和感が少し自分の中に芽生えたんです
私は臨床医という病院働く医者6年やったんですけれども
ずーっと今言ったような違和感と一方で感じるとてつもない充実感
その両方を感じて生きてきました
正直言うと違和感の方から目を背けて
医療を極めようと思って日々目の前のことに一生懸命取り組んで充実感はでそんな生活
をしていました
確かに
大きな病院の中道者には自分の感じた違和感の原因も解決策もわかんなかったわけです
それは自分の問題なのかあるいは自分がその時働いている病院の問題なのかはたまた
医療そのものが問題なのか
それぞれは当時の私には診断が出できなかったんです
でもそんな毎日を過ごしているうちに違和感がどんどん貯まり貯まってあるときどうし
ても我慢ができなくなってその解決を探す家にビジネスクールにことにしました
ビジネスクールに行くことを決めた時に周りの医療従事者
友人の人たちは口々にこう言いました
医療や麺
僕からするとすごくビックリしたのは医療のあり方を突き詰めるためにビジネスクール
に行くそういう選択をしたのに周りからいるを止めるんですか
受け取られちゃうわけです
困ったなぁ
思いながらビジネスくっ行けました
そしたらまた次の驚きがありましたどんな時かというといった先で自分がそれまで培っ
てきたもの
美 u p 医学知識も臨床経験もあるいは思考回路も全く役に立たなかったんです
ついでに言うとアメリカだったので日本語も全然通じなくて苦しい日々が続きました
実は2年間のビジネスクルー留学だったんですがその時のつらさをしゃべろうと思っ
たらたぶん3年間しゃべれるぐらいきつかったんです
でもこれも今日の現代ではないのでここまでにしておきますがそのくらいきつかったん
です
そもそもビジネススクールの学生が何を論点に喋ってるのか全然わかんないんです
彼らの思考回路もわかりませんだって僕からするとどっちでもいいじゃん誰も知らない
よ
終わっちゃうわけです
でもそうする中であることに気づきました今思えばすごく当たり前のことで市民が
そりゃそうだと思うと思うんですが
人はそれぞれ自分の価値観や正義を持っていますそれはみんなバラバラだということ
それは皆さんちょっと言われなくてもわかるよという感じですよね
そして意外なことにその正義や価値観
なかなか交わらないんです
逆に言うとその正義にはある意味半径みたいなものがあって
なかなか交わることがないそんなことなんです
じゃあどうしてそんなことに気づいたかというと
ビジネスクールというところに行って
経営
新しい視座を得て僕は
かつての自分の
正義の中心半径2
見つめ直す機会を得られたからです
そこで気づいたことはたくさんあります例えば
私が医者の当時感じていたものこれは狭い正義
もっと言えば診察しという半径5メートルぐらいの正義の中で語っていた生技でした
確かにその診察の施設の中では医療は全く正しいんです
一方でビジネスクールに行くとこういう人もいました
短期でもいいから
大きな利益を上げられたらそれは成功じゃないか
それはその正義としては正しいと思います
でも聞いている皆さんもどこかでわかるように何となく違和感を感じないかということ
なんですそれは皆さんが今お話しした狭い正義の外から見たとき
なんかおかしいなぁ
そういうは感を感じる自分自身も病院の中で
通じている正義価値観が病院の外に出ると全く通じないそのことに違和感を覚えつつ
充実感でごまかしてきた
そんな自分が見えたわけです
もっと良いこともありました
今お話したようにビジネスクールにってあ自分は医療の正義を持ってたんだな
それから経営の制限を手に入れた
その先に今度は試行錯誤が始まったんですどんな試行錯誤か
この2つをどうやってつなげればいいんだろう
よく言われる話に病院の経営判断と臨床阪南医療の判断がぶつかったときにどうするん
だ
そういう問題があります
その試行錯誤
ビジネスクールに行くことあるいはその後の生活で
することで最終的にその2つを僕は自分の中でつなげるようになりました
そして今では
例えば
もはや医療の価値は延命だけじゃないよねっ
そういうことも受け入れられますし
ビジネスにとって医療はコストではなくて社会の将来に対する投資なんだという主張
することもできます
ですから私にとって医療は難しい病気を治す
それだけのためのものではなくて
どうやったら病気にさせないかあるいは皆さんがずっと元気で過ごすために使えるもの
医療はそういうもんだ
気づいたわけです
今お話ししてきた
店名だけ概要の価値ではないことに気づいてという話でした
それまでの道のりを思い返していくつの気になるポイントがあったんですが今日は皆
さんと3つ
ぜひ協議したいことがありますひとつ目はここに出ているように
目の前の物事を突き詰めてくださいいうことです
目の前の物事を突き詰めるっていうのは自らの価値観や正義それを育てる
唯一の手段だと思いますし何かのものを成し遂げるための最善の方法だと思います
物事を突き詰めると
一瞬視野が狭くなる気がしますそれを嫌がる人がいるのも知っています
オプションが減るのはやだオプションが多い方がいい
波を考えてほしいのはいくら皆さんが人生の選択しオプションを持っていたところで体
は一つでし
時間は皆さんに平等だししかもいう間なんです
選択することを避けて時間を無駄にするくらいだったら一刻も早く
目の前にある物事を突き詰めるということを通して自分を鍛えたり社会に貢献する道を
選んでほしいそう思います
二つ目
これはかすかな違和感を大事にするということです
このかすかな違和感こそが皆さんが育てた価値観や制御を見つめ直すきっかけでもあり
新しい道のりを開く魔法の扉でもあるんです
私自身もそうでした
最初のほうにいったように日々の診療の中で感じてた違和感
これが積み重なって
新たな道のりを探しに行きそして今の自分があるわけです
でも不思議なことに人はこの違和感あるいは自分に対するアラートが苦手です
なぜなら自分の正義の中にいる限りは充実感も得られますし
どちらかというと安心感安定感も得られるからです
だからといってこのアラートに耳をふさいだり
あるいは知らない振りをして自分に引きこもってしまうな最悪なんです
というのは別の新しい価値観や正義に出会ったとき
よくても無視悪いと攻撃するようなことをしてしまう
してしまうからです
そうすると失うものが多くても得るものは何もないんです
これはとてももったいないことだと思います
ですからこのかすかな違和感を大事にするそういう姿勢を常に大事にして欲しいと思い
ます
そして3つ目試行錯誤やがらないん
このことをお勧めします
試行錯誤こそが新しい自分を削り出す貴重な時間です
私もそうでしたさっきも言ったように
医療と
西経営の二つの正義自分の中にあったとき
この2つをどうやってつなげようどうやって価値観を取捨選択して自分なりに解釈しを
納得しよう
これは苦しい日々なんです
答えは自分の中にしかありませんから自分と向き合う日々です自分に問い続ける日々と
いうのは決して楽じゃないんですん
でもある時何かのきっかけで新しい自分が削り出されます
それとともに自分が次に進むべき道法だったりその先に広がる世界を見ることができ
ます
きっかけを様々です
かつてはなんかそれがりんごだったという人もいるらしいのは聞いたことがあります
けれども私の場合は全く果物かそういうものはなくて
むしろ今回こうした場で話すことができること自体
おそらく
病院の中で
あの時はあの時で日々悪戦苦闘してましたけれどもあの子よりアップグレードされたん
だ
いうふうに思います
そういう意味では
物事を突き詰めることそれから日々のかすかな違和感を大事にすることそして試行錯誤
を嫌がらないこと
こうしたことで今自分が進むべき道が見えてきたな
そんな風に思っています
たった今
そうは言いましたけれども実はまだ試行錯誤が続いています
続いているというまた始めたと言ってもいいかもしれません
世界規模の課題の一つである医療という問題
そしてその問題と世界で最も早く向き合い始めた日本という組んで私は起業という選択
肢をとってその解決策を模索しました
正直
企業は
超怖いんです
もともとただ3社ですしビジネスクール言ったって言ったって
ビジネスについて勉強したというだけなんです
ですから私にとって起業するというのはすごく怖かったんです
最悪なことに
起業した後毎日怖いって言う何なんだって話なんですね
起業する前にせっかく悩んだのにしてみたらもっと辛い
でもその試行錯誤の中で
今日お話ししたような新しい自分が削りだされることを知っているので
ある意味で充実した日々だとも言えます
今私に見えている医療の姿あるいはそこに至る道のりはこんな感じです
ずっと元気でいたいあるいはずっと元気でいてほしい
そんな思いを形に変えるよ
そうした医療を実現することが私の理想でありその道程のための試行錯誤は厭わない
そう思えたのも
ここまでの市の日を導いてくれた多くの出会いだったり
あるいは人生の貴重な時間を一緒に過ごしてくれた患者さんたちのおかげだとすごく
思っています
そこはすごく感謝していますん
ですからみなさんもおそらくそれぞれに課題だとか悩みがあると思います
でも今お話ししたような物事を突き詰める姿勢だったり
違和感を大事にする姿勢それから試行錯誤を嫌がらない
そうしたことを
大事にしてもらいたいなというふうに思います
心配は無用です
全力を尽くしてください
小座間でももがいてください
でもかすかな違和感を大事にできる感性も忘れないようにしてください
そうすれば必ず新しい自分が削り出されて
今よりさらに充実した新しい世界道のりが見える私はそう信じていますどうも
ありがとうございました